[Musica]
quanta paura avete di affrontare le
vostre paure
di questi tempi Siamo tutti molto
impegnati ad essere disfatti dal lavoro
dalle ansie dalla famiglia dagli impegni
che abbiamo e tante volte non riusciamo
a soffermarci su noi stessi Non
riusciamo ad analizzarci E cosa ancora
più grave abbiamo paura di guardarci
dentro ci mettiamo di vita dei nostri
lati più scomodi quelli più ingombranti
quelli che probabilmente sono quelli che
conosciamo meglio ma che non vogliamo
ammetterlo
abbiamo così prova di guardarci dentro
che facciamo di tutto per distrarci
facciamo ogni genere di cosa per non
pensare effettivamente come siamo di ciò
che questa società ci aiuta anche a
distrarci abbastanza Nonostante ciò il
rumore che ci tiene sveglio la notte o
che ci sveglia la mattina ci accompagna
costantemente
molte volte è più facile farsi cullare
dal disagio nel quale ci troviamo
piuttosto che ti varsene fuori È molto
facile trovare una zona comfort nel
dolore e penso che tanti di voi
l'abbiano provato io personalmente l'ho
provato e anche qualcuno nella mia
famiglia diverse persone
un esempio che porto e quando ad esempio
ti svegli in un periodo brutto e non ti
alzi dal letto e sei tutta la mattina
guarda il soffitto pensando io so a
letto che sto meglio quando in realtà
non Stai meglio Siamo arrivati in un
punto dove molto più facile viveva in
una bolla di tristezza piuttosto che
uscirne ed è come se avessimo esaurito
le energie per noi stessi dedicandole ad
altro Quindi ricordate importante
soffermarsi su di noi
e è un video in un mondo secondo me
parlo per me Non so quello che voi
pensiate dovete tendenzialmente diamo
molto di più rispetto a quello che
riceviamo soprattutto se siamo persone
educate gentili e tutto ciò poi ti porta
a sentirti vuoto a sentirti senza un
senso perché ciò che lei non è ciò che
dicevi ed è sbagliato aveva aspettative
Però diciamo che un po' più di
equilibrio ci vorrebbe
mio padre lui ad esempio ha fatto di
tutto per la sua famiglia nonostante
avesse una visione diversa dalla loro ha
seguito la sua via e per questo è stato
DJ avevate allontanato dalla famiglia
purtroppo i suoi genitori sono morti e
adesso lui non ha più la possibilità di
affrontare il rumore che ha dentro e col
quale continuava a vivere che purtroppo
l'ha portato a soffri di depressione
d'ansia Quindi quello che voglio dire
anche cercate sempre proprio per questo
di affrontare le vostre prove perché
magari un giorno non avete più il modo e
dovete conviverci per sempre fidatevi
che non è bello
un altro esempio che voglio riportarvi
in questo caso lo dedico a tutte le
donne che probabilmente hanno dato a
nuove a un uomo e sono stati ricambiate
solamente con della manipolazione e che
purtroppo adesso non riescono più ad
avere una relazione come vorrebbero
perché conservano ancora rumore che
fanno fatica ad affrontare
e poi soprattutto voglio ricordare a
tutti i miei coetanei in questo caso
parla anche per i miei amici che
soffrono disturbi mentali piuttosto che
di dipendenze che la sofferenza per
toccare il fondo è la stessa che si
aveva toccava il cielo quindi decidete
voi per cosa soffrire
Ci sono vari tipi di
Ci sono vari tipi di rumori ci sono
quelli ciclici come cantava Antonello
Venditti un po' di quegli amori che
vanno e poi ritornano e poi ci sono
anche dei rumori più improvvisi che
avevano così quando uno meno se
l'aspetta il rumore non per forza deve
essere negativo e nemmeno positivo lo
rimuove una sensazione che noi Proviamo
Nel caso che sto cercando di spiegarvi
all'interno
il rumore è fondamentale in realtà è
fondamentale anche perché ti serve a
fare esplodere proprio la bolla di
malessere nella quale ti puoi trovare
E come lo si fa con un semplice gesso
con un atto con un qualcosa che Bam
rompe tutto c'è anche il rumore della
Liberazione rumore di quando noi
proviamo a fare cose nuove e proviamo
questi voli nuovi conosciamo persone
nuove
e poi c'è il rumore costante che penso
che quello che appartiene un po' più
comunemente a tutti noi e quello che ci
accompagna quotidianamente nel nostro
quotidiano è un rumore che io ho
iniziato a percepire effettivamente
quando ho finito la scuola superiore
perché mi sono ritrovato nel mondo del
lavoro io ho fatto l'istituto
alberghiero diplomato in sala baro
Iniziate a fare il cameriere dopo un
anno capito che mi faccia schifo Non
avevo grandi alternative perché non
avevo idea di cosa potessi studiare di
cosa volessi fare e al contempo mi
continuava a dire Dai provaci che vedi
ci ascolta quello che ti dicono gli
altri quando in realtà probabilmente
avrei potuto cambiare la mia vita prima
invece non l'ho fatto lavorando Ho
capito tante cose di me stesso che mi
son piaciute perché lo capite ma in quel
momento non mi piacevano e mi sono
sentita a disagio mi sono sentito fuori
luogo per il mio modo di essere per il
mio modo di esprimermi di vestirmi mi è
stata fatta pesare la mia onestà al
punto che c'è ho iniziato ad almeno
confidenza sul lavoro perché tutto ciò
che dici può essere usato contro di te
ed è una cosa molto subdola
e poi anche il fatto che secondo me
arriviamo in un mondo dove bisogna
essere e dovere essere c'è sempre questo
essere SS invece ma esseri umani fatti
per essere umani non per essere cioè è
molto semplice sai come concetto è una
cosa che poi ti porta nel mio caso a
sentirti in difetto quindi a dare meno
di te quando io probabilmente sono
persone che in realtà avrei sempre
dovuto dare questa cosa mi ha chiuso per
un po' ma portata a sentirmi
disinteressato disinteressato in tutto
che oggettivamente penso che per quattro
anni abbondanti della mia vita oltre al
lavoro al buttarmi via non abbia avuto
grandi passioni
negli ultimi anni alla fine io ho
lavorato come vai dove ho fatto proprio
la mia grande escalation a livello
lavorativo partito dagli alberghi di
lusso è finita a fare le consegne in
Germania e la cosa più assurda è che
sfociando sulla strada con la
consapevolezza che non riusciva a
trovare la mia strada ho trovato la mia
strada come è successo tramite il caso
penso che il caso sia una delle
componenti più quotidiane della nostra
vita ma che viene sottovalutata perché
il caso non vuol dire che una cosa ti
arriva e ti cambia la vita il caso vuol
dire che ti aveva una cosa poi la devi
saper cogliere e sfruttarla a tuo favore
devi riuscire tu a vendere la tua e a
farti avviare dove vuoi come è arrivato
a me MasterChef per caso io ero in
vacanza in Italia siamo in Germania quel
tempo sono venuta a visitare i miei
genitori e uno dei miei migliori amici
mi sa di Guarda io mi sono iscritto a
Masterchef che fai viene anche tu hai
detto No guarda però di nuovo proprio no
non mi interessa non avevo voglia di
espormi No non avevo ancora capito
effettivamente la mia passione il mio
talento per la cucina quindi dissi no
poi l'altro mio amico mi disse Dai
Iscriviti vai che fate un po' di caccia
vi divertite alla fine mi sono iscritto
io sono stato preso il mio amico No è un
grandissimo paradosso
una volta che va all'interno della
masterclass il nuovo muoversi è spento
perché ho creato un meccanismo da
autodifesa che mi ha portato a isolarmi
a vivere il presente che probabilmente
la condizione più sana per vi è la vita
perché quello che noto è che le ansie
riguardano il futuro e la depressione vi
guarda il passato quando in realtà se
uno riesce a trovare una bolla di
lucidità la tua proprio nel presente e
[Applauso]
la cosa più assurda è che con la
consapevolezza che in ogni attimo io
potevo perdere trova una lucidità che
non ho mai avuto in vita mia cioè 10
secondi 10 secondi finali al prosciutto
nelle prove mi sembra 10 minuti Mentre
gli altri 45 minuti volavano e quindi ho
capito che effettivamente tu puoi
cambiare tutto in un secondo ed è una
bellissima cosa ho scoperto che la
Adrenalina è in grado di annullare i
rumori che nella testa e di darmi
un'energia che non pensavo di avere
derivante da dichiarazioni altrui può
essere schiacciato In che modo
semplicemente avendo un obiettivo che
vale di più di quella persona non so
quante volte vi capita che voi magari
anche al lavoro per dire vi fate
abbattere da un commento del vostro
superiore piuttosto che di un vostro
collega Ricordatevi che voi siete lì per
voi non lo vedi di conseguenza
fregatevenete vincete vincete in quel
modo vincete fregandone facendogli
capire che voi siete di più e che non
devono neanche dirtelo lo dimostro coi
fatti ho capito un'altra cosa
[Applauso]
ho capito un'altra cosa che all'interno
della massa o Class che la patia è
comunque una sensazione è un rumore e
che la puoi combattere come la combatti
emozionandoti conoscendo condividendo Io
sono una persona che nella vita non ha
mai condiviso troppo mi sono sempre
creduto un individualista o in realtà
probabilmente avevo solamente un ottuso
insicuro che non aveva voglia di
mettersi in competizione con gli altri
una volta che mi sono messo in
competizione ho capito che il bello di
condividere la competizione ancora più
bello della competizione in se stessa
perché ti porta a guardarti sotto
un'altra prospettiva e ti porta a
rispettare il tuo avversario di
conseguenza quando tu rispetti il tuo
avversario rispetti te stesso ed è la
cosa più importante avevamo proprio
rispettare se volersi bene cosa che non
so ancora fare ma ci provo
ho capito che la mia esuberanza è la
credibile che la mia follia aveva un
senso ho capito anche di aver fantasia e
creatività perché fin quando cucinava
casa cucinava in un altro modo poi in
quel contesto ho trovato dei lati di me
che non conoscevo grazie grazie
probabilmente all'adrenalina del momento
e la cosa più assurda è che ti volevo
muovere del mixer dei coltelli dei
taglieli che sbattevamo io c'ho il mio
silenzio mi isolavo Cioè mi isolavo
nella mia piccola bolla votata che va la
mia cucinata E vabbè bello c'è una
bellissima se è una bellissima
sensazione sicuramente la mia esperienza
MasterChef è stata la più bella della
mia vita perché ripeto la serenità che
ho trovato lì dentro non l'ho non l'ho
mai provata prima non la sto provando
adesso probabilmente non la prova più ma
perché comunque è una situazione unica
Mi sono reso conto che quando devo
convinto che avevo tutto da perdere col
fatto che fosse la prima aveva
opportunità della mia vita In realtà io
non ci voglio niente da perdere Avevo
solamente da dimostrare qualcosa a me
stesso
oggi ad un anno effettivo della mia
vittoria su un punto a capo ho finito un
ciclo Lo sto finendo oggi qui con voi vi
ringrazio di essere qua perché mi fa
davvero piacere
[Applauso]
e sono tornato punto a capo Nel senso
che io credo che il rumore Sia cicli con
un po' come la vita Io adesso ho finito
una parte della mia vita ne inizio una
nuova non so come andava sto di nuovo
camminando su un filo dove sto in
equilibrio ma ho paura di cadere perché
è normale e quindi mi ritorna un pochino
Quella ronzio di cosa succedeva a
settembre essendo in qualche programma
TV se si continua a lavorare come sto
facendo o se dovrò cambiare lavoro e non
lo so come mi fa stare in realtà No dai
GameStop va bene uguale Io adesso ho
capito una cosa che ho la consapevolezza
di saperle gestire queste situazioni
sono pronto quindi come vada vada un
piano ha un piano B è un piano C Quindi
quelli non me lo toglie nessuno
Grazie
e soprattutto la cosa più importante che
ho capito in quest'ultimo periodo È
stata la prima volta in vita mia che ho
messo di aver bisogno delle persone alle
quali voglio bene nella mia famiglia dei
miei amici e anche delle persone in
generale perché mi sono sentito solo mi
sono sentito vuoto e come sia in questi
cinque mesi sia passato da 0 a 100 abbia
dato tutto senza mai fermarmi un secondo
e appunto in questo mese che ha avuto la
possibilità di fermarmi a nipote totale
pianti la mattina scemi steli che con
mia madre che poverina si deve beccava i
miei sfoghi perché almeno con una
persona Mi devo sfogare ormai essendo
personaggio pubblico non posso neanche
più buttare quello che ho dentro fuori
devo avere i miei piccoli protettori e
il fatto che mi sia reso conto di aver
bisogno di loro ma riempito di nuovo ma
vi portato a far vedere le persone a
stare con loro a condividere me stesso
con loro ed è una cosa che mi fa star
bene Un po' Come essere qua con voi
quando vado in tv Io credo che abbia
bisogno tutti distrarci un pochino di
aver spensieratezza e darla a voi me la
dama di conseguenze Questa è una cosa
impagabile infine voglio dire io sogno
che tutti noi un giorno smetteremo di
darci per vinti
sogno che tutti noi possiamo essere più
sereni perché credo che chiunque qua la
serenità l'abbia provata almeno una
volta e una volta che tu fai un'emozione
la puoi riprovare devi solamente tu hai
la chiave io nel mio caso spero di
trovare la continuando nel mondo dello
spettacolo qui lo dico qui lo nego più
che cucinavo vorrei fare spettacolo
vediamo come andrà e soprattutto
Ricordiamoci una cosa che il sogno ci
tiene vivi alleniamoci a sentire i
rumori più belli e viviamo e voglio
concludere così sentiamo il rumore
costantemente ma inizia anche a fare
rumore e daje Grazie